all right welcome back I'm so excited
here I'm in the kitchen with all of
these wonderful Libations because it is
the festive time of season who better to
show us than Station Casinos corporate
mixologist Jamie Clark uh Jamie joining
us this morning first of all it is her
birthday everyone so happy birthday
December baby and you're here nice and
early to make some cocktails for us and
this is all of stations where you can
pick up these yummy Libations absolutely
what have you got for us yeah so we have
so many amazing things
Board of things
um we have some of our winner at the
Terrace cocktails here okay a winner at
the Terrace for folks who don't know
that's at Green Valley Ranch and it's
like a pop-up Christmas explosion right
yes yeah just a winter themed outdoor
lounge we have four igloos so they're
super cozy so you can sit out in these
igloos right yes igloos we have fire
pits where you can do like a s'mores fun
we have a hot chocolate cart that's
amazing oh my gosh so some of the hot
chocolates are there wait so here in the
front these are those um let's see if we
can get a picture there we go these um
cocoa bombs you said we have yeah
we have no chocolate and dark chocolate
Okay so that's for maybe the kids
because that would be the non-alcoholic
version there is an alcohol add-on oh
you can add on well that's that's where
I that's where I'm happy about that
that's good now the food items here that
you have on display these are available
at the event as well someone are at the
Terrace so amazing cupcakes
um there's some deviled eggs there with
some caviar all produced by our amazing
culinary team at Green Valley Ranch oh
Jamie these are just stunning but let's
jump into the drinks I know a lot of
people like to enjoy a little festive
libation for the season what do you have
yeah so at when are the Terrace we have
a couple things going on we have our
polar expresso here it's kind of like an
espresso martini with some creme de mint
and a New Orleans style coffee oh I love
it with a rosemary cranberry we have our
naughty toddy with some Crown Apple in
there spiced apple cider keep you nice
and warm on the inside right because the
hot bodies uh the naughty toddy is warm
okay this is our frostbite a different
take on a coconut kind of drink it has
some Reposado tequila Tennessee whiskey
oh I looked at this one online and that
would definitely be where I would go
that's a nice little concoction of fun
right there and then yeah we have um so
this is we'll we'll be jumping over to
our kind of our Global holiday cocktails
at some of the other properties
um this is going to be my s'more rum rum
Rudolph it's like a s'mores shot oh
let's see yeah
see how we can make this up and and
enjoy a little it's never too early to
enjoy a cocktail right Jamie
so we start by with having a graham
cracker Rim I'm gonna go with some
Captain Morgan okay Captain Morgan
awesome we have some Bailey's s'mores
that's perfect
we'll grab that in a minute and then
this is the important one right yes I'm
Mr black coffee liqueur oh
so that's beautiful and I'm sorry you
call this the Run Run Rudolph
that is perfect
all right
she knows what she's doing this is how
you make cocktails folks
and Jamie they can come see you at
stations
you're behind the scenes okay you're the
Run rum of this
oh and look at that nice and creamy
beautiful cocktails again so these are
available at Station Casinos you can
make some fun cocktails at home and then
of course you have winter on the Terrace
they're happening at Green Valley Ranch
uh reservations yes we recommend
reservations for the winter at the
Terrace oh and look at this yeah and so
that's the s'more shot and then we just
give it a little torque oh it smells
really good oh
I'm gonna drink all these while I send
it back over to Sherry uh maybe Sherry
I'll save one for you what do you think